humanity is obsessed
with the superlative
the biggest the fastest the strongest
the most destructive
even after the world witnessed the
devastation wrought by atomic weaponry
during world war ii
we inexplicably built them bigger
bolder
and more deadly
on october the 30th 1961 a tupolov tu95v
bomber opens its doors and drops its 27
ton load over nevaya zamla island in the
soviet arctic ocean
the immense bomb descends almost
gracefully beneath parachutes allowing
its plane to speed away as fast as its
propellers will take it
which is just as well
for when this tsar bomba or king of
bombs detonates
it produces
the largest man-made blast
the world
has ever seen
the thermonuclear weapon explodes with a
force of 50 megatons of tnt more than 3
800 times stronger than the bomb dropped
on hiroshima
its mushroom cloud reaches 60 kilometers
in height and the flash of the
detonation could be seen a thousand
kilometers away
the heat from the explosion is enough to
cause third degree burns at the distance
of a hundred kilometers
the colossal destructive force of the
tsar bomber explosion was hard to fathom
but earlier that year astronomers had
witnessed an explosion that was some 10
billion billion times stronger
in a spiral galaxy 45 million light
years away from our own a giant star
reached the end of its life in
spectacular fashion
as fusion came to a halt in its core the
repulsion of its electrons could no
longer resist the crushing force of
gravity and it collapsed in on itself at
nearly a quarter of the speed of light
the sudden implosion sends temperatures
soaring and results in a supernova
explosion that spews stellar material
over many light years
but if supernova explosions are more
powerful than anything we can conceive
of on earth
hypernovas put even them to shame
these rare super powerful stellar
explosions result from the death of
stars more than 30 times more massive
than our sun a black hole is created in
the center and scorching winds of newly
forged nickel and jets of radiation
plough through and ignite what was left
of the star
hypernovae can be 10 to 100 times
brighter and more powerful than a
supernova
they are believed to be the most
powerful single event in our observable
universe
and all of this destructive force
results
ultimately from the pull of gravity on
the atoms that make up these dying stars
so you could be forgiven for thinking of
gravity as vastly powerful
indeed every moment of our lives is
shaped and defined by gravity
from the convenience of remaining stuck
to the surface of the earth to the
mental calculations we make when playing
sports even to the immense challenge of
engineering rockets to escape our
planet's inexorable pull
but gravity is just one of four
fundamental forces that control our
universe
the strong nuclear force holds our atoms
together the electromagnetic force
permeates all of space and delivers the
radiation which lights and warms the
cosmos even the weak nuclear force has a
vital purpose driving the nuclear fusion
in the hearts of stars
indeed when compared to these other
heavy hitters the force of gravity pales
in comparison
the strong force is fittingly the
strongest force known to nature followed
by the electromagnetic force and then
unsurprisingly the weak force
and at the bottom of the scale
gravity
by some distance
it is weaker even than the so-called
weak force
to be exact
by 10 to the 25th power or 10 trillion
trillion times
in order for us to feel the effects of
gravity we must work on cosmological
scales with entire stars and planets
worth of accumulated matter
in simple terms the stored chemical
energy in the legs of an ant can
overcome the gravity of an entire world
[Music]
gravity's relative weakness has baffled
scientists for years and has come to be
known as the hierarchy problem
and this mystery may be linked to
another cosmological puzzle
where does this omnipresent but
practically powerless force
originate
to answer these century-old questions we
will have to take a trip billions of
years back in time
billions of light years away in space
and possibly even
to another dimension
[Music]
this video is sponsored by
curiositystream the documentary
subscription service question how big
was the largest black hole ever
discovered a a billion times the size of
our sun b roughly the size of the milky
way c
very big or d
not very big
ton 618 is 66 billion solar masses
similar in size to the entire milky way
and so my recommendation from
curiositystream this month is the
fascinating zenith advances in space
exploration a new 13-part series
exploring just how humanity will be able
to journey to the stars
and for this and more curiosity stream
is a bargain at less than 20 dollars a
year with a wide range of documentaries
on topics ranging from science to music
nature to sports with new shows popping
up every week so go to
curiositystream.com forward slash
history of the universe
to sign up and using the promo code
history of the universe will save you 25
percent
[Music]
gravity was the first force to be
recognized by scientists and yet to this
day
remains the most shrouded in mystery
isaac newton may have been a brilliant
mathematician but he was by all the
counts a dower and serious man with no
time or interest for the opposite sex or
indeed any sex at all he remained a
virgin all his life and what joy he
experienced was scarcely visible on his
face
legend has it he only laughed in public
twice
but of course it was under this ultimate
focus distracted by neither jolity or
intimacy that newton was able to
formulate his famous theory of universal
gravitation
[Music]
in 1666 the deadly outbreak of plague
forced cambridge university to close and
newton returned to his family home
wolves thought manor in lincolnshire
here in an isolation much like that
experienced by many of us in the last
two years newton found himself uniquely
inspired
he continued to experiment with light
and optics and took long walks around
the grounds where it is said he
witnessed something that would come to
define physics
whether or not this is myth it was a
myth perpetuated by newton himself
after dinner the weather being warm we
went into the garden and drank tea under
the shade of some apple trees he told me
he was just in the same situation as
when formally the notion of gravitation
came into his mind it was occasioned by
the fall of an apple as he sat in
contemplative mood
why should that apple always descend
perpendicularly to the ground thought he
to himself
letting his mind wander above the
branches of the apple tree he further
considered this attractive force
extending beyond the atmosphere of the
earth
in that moment he didn't understand
gravity in its entirety but as the apple
struck the ground it sowed the seeds of
his pivotal theory
that theory simply is that all masses
experience an attractive force pulling
them together the strength of that force
is proportional to their respective
masses and inversely proportional to the
distance between them
early 18th century scholars applying
newton's theory of universal gravitation
found that it worked remarkably well to
explain the motions of the planet's
moons and stars
but newton in characteristically dour
and pessimistic fashion was still not
satisfied
that gravity should be innate inherent
and essential to matter or that one body
may act upon another at a distance is to
me so great in absurdity that i believe
no man who has in philosophical matters
a competent faculty of thinking can ever
fall into it
gravity must be caused by an agent
acting constantly according to certain
laws
but whether this agent be material or
immaterial i have left to the
consideration of my readers
in other words the maths is correct but
he has no idea why
but while this mysterious agent remained
undiscovered newton's theory persisted
for some 200 years
over that time more precise astronomical
observations gradually revealed
phenomena that the so-called universal
gravitation was unable to explain
the orbit of mercury for instance didn't
conform to the mathematical dance
predicted by newton's theory and the
equations also came short of explaining
how a light with no measurable mass of
its own could be bent and deflected by
other objects
newton's self-skepticism was justified
and ahead of its time
the gravity of the situation became
increasingly apparent to early 20th
century astronomers as more and more
advanced telescopes and instruments
began to probe the cosmos on scales
never before imagined time and time
again newton's theory fell short and it
became clear that a more nuanced
mathematical explanation for gravity
would be necessary
and so in 1913 an alternative theory was
proposed
but not
by the man
you may imagine
gunnar nordstrom was a finnish physicist
hugely inspired by certain germans
recent theories of special relativity in
which space and time themselves are
redefined as phenomena intrinsically
tied to frames of reference
nordstrom seized upon and solved the
equations set by the german and went on
to expand his own theories to consider
how this might apply to gravitational
attractions
in them he posited a notion that must
have seemed outrageous as it was
difficult to grasp
what if
nordstrom suggested space and time were
not flat
but instead
curved
[Music]
such a bizarre dimensional geometry
would be enough to explain gravitation
just as well as newton's theory even
better in some circumstances
unfortunately although nordstrom's
mathematics were internally consistent
they couldn't be confirmed by experiment
or observation a solar eclipse in 1919
revealed bending of light that didn't
fit with his theory's predictions
nordstrom's ideas were dead in the water
but the seed of curved space-time had
already been sown
the very german physicist whose
equations first guided the fin now
seized upon his revolutionary ideas and
made them his own
two years after nordstrom the german
albert einstein published his own theory
of general relativity with curved
space-time central to all observable
features of gravity
but far from being resentful nordstrom
nominated his friend and colleague for
the nobel prize
twice
einstein himself found it helpful to
think about the naughty questions
surrounding the nature of gravity with
his gadankan experiments
he created an entire laboratory
of thought experiments
in one notionally inspired by seeing a
painter fall from a roof opposite the
painted building where he worked he
imagines a man falling from an
impossibly tall building
as he falls untroubled by fear of any
imminent impact he may consider whether
he is in fact
falling at all
if he releases any object he was holding
it would remain in the same position
beside him he would be forgiven for
thinking that there was no gravitational
field at all that he was floating
weightless and at rest in space
such a comparison serves to demonstrate
that our perception of gravity is
strongly dependent on our frame of
reference only by looking at the windows
of the building scrolling past would our
luckless man be aware of his imminent
fate
another of einstein's thought
experiments places our unfortunate
falling man inside a large closed box
that is this time floating freely in
space he would be truly weightless
within it that box then has a rope
attached to a surface that was to become
its roof and that rope is pulled on by
some divine and omnipotent being with a
constant force
the box would be accelerated uniformly
upwards and the man inside would drop to
the floor
all his senses would tell him that he
now has weight he's indeed sitting on
the floor of the box as he would if the
box was sitting on the surface of a
planet like earth
he could be forgiven for thinking that
he was in a uniform gravitational field
when in reality no such field exists
this example serves to demonstrate that
the effects of gravitational
acceleration are indistinguishable from
those of a more traditional
force-induced acceleration the likes of
which we experience in a speeding car or
a cornering roller coaster
this so-called equivalence may seem
obvious to us but it became an important
facet of einstein's theory of general
relativity
although physicists are still looking
for ways to experimentally verify this
equivalence and other assumptions that
underpin general relativity the advanced
theory first proposed in 1915 still
holds up to detailed examination
general relativity relates mata's energy
and momentum to the curvature of
space-time which in turn dictates how
everything embedded within it both
material and intangible
behaves
importantly the theory is able to
explain the strange wobble in mercury's
orbit since the tiny planet passes so
close to the massive sun that it
receives an extra relativistic push and
general relativity also satisfactorily
explains the curvature of massless light
all of our perceived reality resides
within the four dimensions of space-time
and is a slave to the geometry of that
fabric if space-time is curved by
massive objects
then light has no choice but to curve as
well
today we have tested general relativity
time and time again and it does appear
to hold true but while einstein's
theories broke ground in describing how
gravity works on cosmological scales
they do little to reveal the true nature
and origin of this mysterious force
in other words echoing newton's
statement 250 years earlier the maths
checks out
but we still don't know why
physicists have spent the last hundred
years searching for gravity's beginnings
in the hope that it will shed light on
its true nature why it is ultimately so
weak
and even
how the universe around it
came into existence
[Music]
one billion years ago on earth
not a lot was happening
[Music]
for roughly 800 million years the planet
has been stuck in a stagnant stinking
stasis
no major continental reshuffles no
waxing and waning ice ages no
fluctuations in oceanic or atmospheric
chemistry
life which has made promising advances
since its appearance diversifying
throughout the oceans inventing
photosynthesis and even learning how to
cooperate
now just seems to
stop
in its tracks
evolution stalled and for this
unthinkably vast span of time amounting
to nearly a quarter of all of earth's
history
nothing very interesting happened at all
this period has been fittingly named the
boring billion by geologists
and yet
in the earth's distant southern skies
far beyond the magellanic clouds an
event is taking place
that is by no means
boring
[Music]
two black holes each more than thirty
times the mass of our own sun
are locked in a fatal dance spinning
faster and faster around one another
until eventually catastrophically they
collide
merging to become one's super-sized body
unfortunately for the proterozoic earth
this spectacular event is unable to
punctuate the tedium as not only are the
black holes themselves non-luminous and
therefore invisible but they are also
more than a billion light years away
there's nothing for anyone or anything
to see hear or feel
for a billion years
until at 9 50 a.m on the 14th of
september 2015 a remarkable instrument
comes online
two advanced laser interferometer
gravity wave observatories known as ligo
had just been completed in hanford
washington and in livingston louisiana
and had been switched on
just two days before
they were still in their test mode with
no formal research having begun when
researchers picked up an incredibly loud
and clear signal it was so perfect that
nobody believed at first that it was
real they thought it was just another
calibration signal designed to test the
instrument's sensitivity and the
researcher's analytical skills
but when no one owned up to devising
such a drill they were forced to
conclude that their brand new detector
had made its first detection
this was in itself remarkable throughout
its proposal funding and construction
ligo received more than its fair share
of criticism indeed the instrument had
been conceived as a way to detect a
phenomenon that had only ever existed as
a theory it was einstein himself who
posited the idea of gravitational waves
radiating out through space-time from a
sudden and massive gravitational
disturbance
but space-time is our reality so how
could we possibly detect ripples within
it without anything to compare it
against
ligo intended to search for these minute
distortions using two lasers reflected
back and forth between a sequence of
mirrors which then converge at a single
point to cancel each other out if a
gravitational wave passed through they
would change the lengths of these laser
beams causing a mismatch that could be
detected at the point of convergence
critics doubted that the instrument
would be sensitive enough to detect
these faint ripples or indeed that they
existed at all
so it's little wonder that scientists
were surprised by their discovery in
2015.
the signal they detected was short
lasting just a fifth of a second but
corresponded to a vibration that was in
the range of human hearing
[Music]
and the source of this chirp
the cataclysmic collision of two black
holes more than a billion years ago
the merger had released nearly a
quindicilian joules of energy that's 10
to the 48th power as gravitational waves
radiated out in all directions traveling
at light speed for a billion years until
they finally reached ligo just two days
after it came online
and since that first remarkable
detection scientists have heard
countless more chirps and beeps from
gravitational waves rippling through the
fabric of the cosmos
their success was confirmed beyond a
doubt in 2017 when the detection of
gravitational waves coincided with a
burst of gamma rays and then
observational evidence of a bright new
star the source this time was not
merging black holes but merging
neutron stars
ligo's critics were firmly silenced as
the researchers were awarded the 2017
nobel prize in physics for their
definitive detection of gravitational
waves and further confirmation of
einstein's general relativity
but what does this cutting-edge science
tell us about the nature of gravity in
the cosmos
the existence of gravitational waves
implies that gravity is not simply a
force between individual objects but a
field that extends throughout all space
and time
ripples move through that field at the
speed of light not instantaneously as
newton's original formulations implied
that means that if the sun were to
suddenly blink out of existence the
earth would continue orbiting the space
it had inhabited for a full eight
minutes
unaware that anything had changed before
the change in gravitational distortion
caught up
disconcerting though this may seem for
physicists it is a comforting conclusion
the other fundamental forces are also
manifest as fields with energy being
transmitted through them as waves
light and heat are just ripples in the
pervasive electromagnetic field of the
cosmos and are two limited to a maximum
speed
so we would be ignorant to the
disappearance of the sun's light too for
a full eight minutes
gravity therefore behaves similarly to
the other forces and it's not
unreasonable to think that its origin
can be tied to them
as well
and it is in the pursuit of this mystery
that lycos scientists hope gravitational
waves can provide another clue
today we detect space-time ripples all
the time from things like black holes
neutron stars and supernovae
but theoretically there should be
another wave lurking in the background
behind all the noise of the lives and
deaths of stars
astronomers believe that there should be
faint gravitational ripples pervading
the universe
which have been travelling the vast
cosmic ocean
since its birth
[Music]
currently accepted models for the
universe's earliest moments see the
newborn cosmos suddenly and almost
instantaneously expand
inflating to many uncountable trillions
times its original size in less than a
billionth of a billionth of a billionth
of a second
whatever heat and energy that had
existed in the universe before inflation
was now spread unimaginably thinly
leaving space cold and empty
yet of course that is not how the cosmos
is today so cosmologists imagine a
period of reheating that immediately
followed
they hypothesized that whatever force
field or particle that was responsible
for inflation in the first place decayed
away and transformed into energy and
particles to fill the new universe
this is considered by some to be the
real big bang since this is the event
that filled the cosmos with everything
needed to make our universe as we know
it
and theory suggests that this reheating
event would have released energy in the
form of gravitational waves which would
have spent the last 13.8 billion years
traveling through the fabric of
space-time
they would be faint but these primordial
echoes if our theories are correct are
washing over us
right now
unfortunately the groundbreaking ligo
instruments in washington and louisiana
may be able to pick up a black hole
merger a billion light years away but
they are not sensitive enough to probe
the beginning of the universe
new instruments are being developed
right now including the european space
agency's laser interferometer space
antenna
or lisa
which it is hoped will have the
resolution to filter out the clamor from
the stars to see the swell of space-time
itself
the types of waves these new instruments
detect also offer a chance for us to
better understand the process and end of
inflation
it is a period of time we will never be
able to probe with traditional astronomy
since the universe was no more than an
opaque plasma until it was around 380
000 years old and inflation occurred
less than a second after the true big
bang
we don't know if reheating was slow or
rapid but the pattern of gravitational
waves from each scenario would be
sufficiently different to allow us to
reconstruct this remarkable event
the detection of primordial
gravitational waves from the end of
inflation would also confirm another
assumption
that the gravitational field itself is
intrinsic to the universe as we know it
while it may seem obvious and reinforced
by gravity's similarity to the other
four fundamental forces it is an
important experimental result that
provides boundaries on what is and isn't
likely during this improbable period in
the history of the universe
today the shape of space-time is warped
by the presence of massive objects
does the gravitational field require
mass in order to manifest
results from the large hadron collider
in 2012 verified that the mass of normal
matter is derived from the higgs field
and its corresponding messenger particle
the higgs boson
but modelling suggests that the higgs
field didn't come into existence until
long after the end of inflation
so is this the origin of the
gravitational field as well
while the link between mass and gravity
in the modern universe is indisputable
they are in fact separate and mutually
exclusive phenomena
the einsteinian notion of gravity is in
fact created by a combination of energy
and momentum not explicitly
mass
this much is apparent by gravity's
effect on the massless photons that make
up light
and so gravity doesn't need the higgs
field to work
its origin can long predate the origin
of mass in the cosmos
although its effects become
unrecognizable in a universe where
matter and mass are not yet related
and so the general consensus among early
universe cosmologists is that gravity
emerged during the bizarre and
incomprehensible
planck epoch
when the universe was just a planck
length in size around a hundred billion
billionths the size of a proton
but the nature of that gravity would be
very different to that in the modern
cosmos
efforts to probe the behavior of
gravitational space-time on such small
scales have yielded troubling and
unsatisfactory answers but new ideas are
gaining ground which offered to
transform our understanding again just
as einstein's revelations and ligo's
discoveries have done before these
theories are as mind-boggling as any in
the pre-inflationary universe
but they offer to resolve the
long-standing and as yet unresolved
question
of why gravity is so mysterious
and
so weak
lisa randle is filled with confidence
and adrenaline as she chalks her hands
and flexes her fingers ready for the
climb ahead of her
stepping back to check her planned route
for the final time she sees chalk on
handholds favored by previous climbers
and pins and hooks ready for securing
ropes at stages along the vertical rock
face
she isn't nervous just the day before
she had scaled yosemite's famous half
dome and is feeling comfortable in her
climbing prime
happy and confident she steps up to the
rock eases her toes into a crack
and begins
her ascent
randle is no stranger to gravity and to
its weakness in comparison with the
other fundamental forces
by 2003 she had made a name for herself
as an instinctive and especially
talented theoretical physicist with some
seemingly outlandish but potentially
inspired theories on the nature of
reality but right now her thoughts are
not of her theories
or of the upcoming conference in which
hundreds of like-minded physicists will
discuss her work
but rather the rock that is mere inches
from her nose and the rough surface of
the stone beneath her fingers
gravity is so weak that here in yosemite
as with everywhere on earth the tension
in a single rope is enough to overcome
it and hold a human body when fingers
slip
unfortunately for lisa randle she is
near the top of the first leg of her
climb and is yet to secure a rope to the
first anchor point just a few feet above
and it is here her hold fails
and gravity takes over
for all its weakness when there is
nothing to stand in its way its speeds
randall back to her starting point
accelerating her by 22 miles an hour for
every second
perform
one of the major barriers to
understanding gravity in the way that we
do the other forces is the fundamental
incompatibility of the two leading
theories in physics
general relativity as defined by
einstein describes the large-scale
behavior and interaction of objects
within a curved spacetime
but at the other end of the physics
spectrum quantum mechanics has been
adopted to explain behaviors on the
smallest possible scales
almost all large-scale phenomena have
been broken down into their smallest
constituent parts the fundamental
particles or virtual particles that
represent the quantized universe
thus the electromagnetic field that
permeates all of space has been
quantized into individual packets or
particles known as photons the other
forces likewise have virtual quantum
particles in the shape of gluons and w
and z bosons that communicate their
action across various scales even the
fundamental particles of mata have been
recognized as quantum manifestations of
a pervasive energy field
but gravity
is the exception to the rule
a quantum messenger particle for the
gravitational field has been theorized
and even given a name
the graviton
but it has never been detected
some doubt that it ever could be
detected if the gravitational field is
woven into space-time then isolating the
quantum packet of that field would be
nion impossible tantamount to reducing
our reality to the 4d pixels that make
it up
such pixels would of course only appear
when viewed from outside the fabric
itself something which we are simply
unable to do
and if it were possible the energies
required to resolve a graviton in a
particle accelerator would require an
instrument with a diameter larger than
our solar system
and on top of this traditionally
mathematically supported theories of
gravity begin to break down at the
smallest scales of quarks and leptons
general relativity suggests that any
source of energy or momentum should
distort space-time this means when you
attempt to quantize space-time to the
smallest degree then gravity itself
becomes an excitation a source of energy
that energy is enough to distort
space-time to create more gravity which
creates more excitations more energy
more gravity more excitation
and so on
unresolvable infinities are bad news for
any theory
this self-excitation like the
uncontrollable fishtailing of a trailer
at high speed is actually not uncommon
in quantum theory but physicists have
found a way to mathematically constrain
and correct for the so-called
self-energy but when it comes to
quantizing gravity and space-time there
are no simple measurements that could be
made to rein in the self-excitation
physicists describe gravity as
non-re-normalizable which essentially
means that space time and gravity cannot
behave in the way we expect at scales
smaller than the planck scale
gravity and the quantum world remain
irrevocably at
odds scientists have suggested alternate
theories for the earliest gravity that
existed during the planck epoch
loop quantum gravity is a scheme that
conveniently avoids the need to
renormalize quantum gravitational
measurements by considering gravity in a
purely geometric sense
rather than as a force
in it space and time are constructed
from closed loops that are woven into an
extremely fine network
transforming the fabric of space-time
from mere metaphor to reality
string theory provides an alternative
but no less mind-melting approach
in it reality is composed of tiny
vibrating strings that exist over more
dimensions than we can possibly ever
experience
it suggests that the three dimensions of
space and one of time are merely
emergent properties of a bigger reality
and so it is here
we return
to yosemite
lisa randall wakes as she is airlifted
from the site of her decisive defeat in
the battle against gravity her head
swimming she sees not stars
but strings but as her consciousness
trickles back the tantalizing glimpse of
multiple dimensions granted to her by
concussive imagination is replaced with
disappointing lucidity
she's back in the limited
three-dimensional world of the living
for the next few months under enforced
bed rest she finally has time to finish
her book and to try to explain her
bizarre multi-dimensional theories in a
way that everyone
can understand
scholars of string theory generally
assume that the other seven dimensions
necessary for the theory to work aren't
visible to us because they are curled up
to an imperceivably tiny scale
but randall went so far as to suggest
that these extra dimensions could be
infinite in extent
provided space had a warped geometry
taking nordstrom and einstein's concepts
of curved space-time to another level
randle suggests that our entire universe
inhabits a three-dimensional pocket of
higher dimensional space
these pockets are known
as brains
from the concept of membranes
just like a pearl on a string can move
side to side and experience only one
linear dimension in our
three-dimensional universe
so our entire universe may be limited to
three dimensions even though many more
exist beyond our reach
and randle invokes these brains as an
elegant explanation for gravity's
elusiveness
and its weakness
she suggests that gravity is not a
fundamental property of the brain we
inhabit
but that it is concentrated in another
brain altogether
this helps to resolve the unanswered
question of why gravity is so weak and
is indeed so much weaker than it should
be indeed mathematical calculations from
first principles suggest that gravity
should in fact be 10 million billion
times as strong as it is
the fact that it is not has been
explained by another theoretical scheme
known as supersymmetry in which every
particle has a supersymmetric sparticle
that helps to shield it from some of the
effects of the ambient
universe but following this theory
through to its natural conclusion that
many spartacles throughout the cosmos
would produce reactions that are simply
not observed
so lisa randle and her colleague raman
sundrum found a way to keep the maths
and explain what we actually see
by effectively quarantining some parts
of the theory in another universe
and so placing gravity on another
four-dimensional brain which is
separated from our own by a short
distance in a five-dimensional bulk
helps to resolve the contradictions
inherent in supersymmetry in this scheme
the effects of gravity decrease
exponentially the further we are from
the so-called
gravibrane
thus in our reality we experience only
those gravitational effects that leak
through from the dimensions where
gravity is king
our lack of success in detecting
gravitons thus far may be a symptom not
of their diminutiveness
but rather the very small quantum
probability that they will stray from
their own brain into our universe
lisa randall's ideas are tantalizing
ones and super symmetry string theory
and the multiverse are concepts that are
rapidly gaining ground within the
physics community
[Music]
but it is hard to set such store by
mathematics alone
just as curved space-time seemed
unfathomably complex to nordstrom and
einstein's predecessors
so these new theories skirt the
worryingly incomprehensible
and just as gravitational waves were
criticized until the moment of their
discovery many scientists won't take
these concepts seriously until there is
definitive proof
if definitive proof
is even possible
with hundreds of physicists astronomers
and mathematicians now working on the
problem all over the world
we will just have to wait
to finally unravel the true nature of
gravity
and reality
itself
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching
and we'll see you
next time